Hello 大家好 我是[来源标识已去除]欢迎大家来到[来源标识已去除]亲自研发和[来源标识已去除]联合出品的这一个拼多多运营成长试验课的课程概述
这节课程呢五分钟左右的时间大家一定要听完
因为这个地方我会跟大家去讲我出这份课程的目的
以及适合听的对象和不适合听的对象
以及最后你听完这套课程你有哪些收获
第一个课程的目的呢一共有四个明确方向少走弯路
减少亏损培养团队
因为这套课程里面我会带你从零到一360度无死角彻彻底底的玩转
当下2026年以后的拼多多
以前的拼多多根本就不适合以前的方法论去进行做
原因很简单
现在的拼多多和以往完全是两个不同的一个规则和运营的一个技巧
第二个有基础 有逻辑 有方案 有付费 有运营
从十个模块里面带你重新认识整个拼多多的运营技巧
平台的认知 开店的入门 店铺的经营 市场的分析 选品的技巧
营销的工具 链接的标准化 活动的营销 付费推广 实操玩法
一共69节课程带你一次性听懂 做好 学的会 实操 能落地 彻彻底底的玩转整个拼多多
一定要仔细认真的去听 这是第一个叫明确方向
第二个 少走弯路 解决所有拼多多商家运营的基础和运营的实操问题
您到一 [来源标识已去除]赖帮你去进行搭建 完成 落地
第三个 减少亏损 帮助商家从您到一去搭建适合自己的运营体系和方法
毕竟基础打得牢 爆款少不了
所有的玩法的根基式基础并不是多牛逼的黑科技和所谓的运营技巧
第三个 培养团队 让更多愿意深根拼多多的商家 工厂
品牌方 持续收益 持续放大 因为你们会去招新的运营助理过来
过来了 你让他听[来源标识已去除]的这69节课
甚至后面我可能会有一些额外的惊喜 陆陆续续给你更新个两节三节四节
甚至70多节课程 让他们能明白怎么做好拼多多
怎么能成为一个合格的拼多多运营
那么适合听的对象呢 就有严重
第一个 适合听的人 简单
第三 想认认真真在拼多多做生意的商家
如果你不想认认真真地去做生意
可以不用去听这些课
你后面的课程听了也对你没有多大的帮助
第二个 想学点正经的电商运营技术的商家运营品牌或者是运营助理
因为很多人想在拼多多里面去学一些乱马其造的黑科技
我告诉你很简单的东西
当下的整个拼多多 我做了这么多年
我很负责任地告诉你 拼多多没有太多的黑科技
由 平台他也会被他堵上
毕竟这个平台已经走了将近十年左右的一个时间了
应该一切向前看 向更正统的运营去进行靠拢
向传统的电商平台所有的步伐去进行靠拢
黑科技越来越少
第三个 想长期稳定在拼多多经营运营的一个商家
毕竟没有任何一个技巧和一个方法
能让你每天都能得到一千单 一万单甚至十万单
只有通过不断的经验的积累 基础的搭建 运营的团队的整体的一个协作
才能让你在拼多多越走越远 越走越稳
比的不是谁快 比的是谁能走得远 谁能走得更稳
最后一个 想搭建属于自己的拼多多运营团队的商家
毕竟很多听[来源标识已去除]课的 尤其是听这堂课的都是夫妻老婆店
或者刚刚出来创业的小白
只有一个人 客服自己 运营自己 打包自己 仓储自己 美工自己
等等等等这些都是你一个人
但是呢 你可以把这个课程系统性的学完之后
后期再去进行招人的时候
你可以一个点一个点一个点的去交给你下面的员工和运营助理
那么不适合听的对象呢 就自己看一下
想一夜报单 不建议听此刻 对你没有用
一点帮助没有
第二个 想运用系统去卡所谓的bug 所谓的漏洞也别听
听了对你也没有多大的帮助
第三个 想学黑方法的人也不太适合
拼多多的现在就是很早很早之前的淘宝
一定是向正规化 品牌化 品质化去进行发展
很多的人都在想一个问题
很多的传统的电商的老板刚做拼多多
或者已经做了传统的电商很多年
他有天猫的团队 抖音的团队 视频号的团队 直播的团队
就是没有拼多多团队
因为他不把拼多多当回事
我希望这套课程给大家最大的收益是
你可以按照[来源标识已去除]十个模块里面每一个东西
一点一点把自己的基础框架搭完
0到1[来源标识已去除]来帮你完成
1到1你后期做的好了
你可以继续去进行深造
毕竟我们还有更多的陪跑
进阶的课程
线下的入住
品牌的孵化
品牌的顾问等等等等这些
最后呢
课程会有两个方向的收益
第一个呢
知识的收益是什么
从入门 基础 运营 爆款的全部过程都有
不管你是不是小白
运营大神 工厂 老商家 品牌商家
你都应该值得把拼多多
用2026年全新的思维重新去做一遍
这个就是我出这些课程最大的目的
因为现在很多的商家
商家做三件事情
开店 商链接 付费
没有了
不知道怎么去进行优化
不知道怎么把自己的公司
把自己的小团队
把自己的工作室越做越好
越走越稳
这些课程就会帮助你去解决这个问题
为什么
因为十个模块的课程
让你可以随时随地的去进行学习
观看 反复
哪里不会你看哪里就可以了
你招的员工也是一模一样
并且这个课程的有效期呢
我们暂时设置的是一年
但是这个课程我可以给大家去保证
你用了一年 两年 三年都没有太多这个问题
后面呢我也会陆陆续续把这个观看时长
给大家去进行解开
大多数人现在刚进这个课的时候
可能都是一年
我们后期如果看到你天天都在这里面学习
你可以找半砖申请
无限期永久去进行观看
这是我能给到你们的一个权限
那么运营的收益是什么呢
第一个 很多的人现在做拼应用的应该高效
运营的工具呢
多店铺的一些管理
差别的举报 视频的采集
等等
非鸟的工具箱里面就有这样的一个东西
你们可以自己记录一下
那么非鸟的工具箱里面有哪些东西呢
这个地方就不再一一跟大家去进行介绍了
你自己去下载一个
你自己去进行体验一下
你就明白了有一个免费试用的一个权限
第二个
裂便的工具呢
就是拼多多店铺的后台
有一个非鸟商品管理
我建议你们
如果在店铺里面铺货搬家裂便
建议用非鸟商品管理
不要用工具箱里面的模拟人工
站在我的角度
我希望你们要做的一件事情
就是用更高效
更正规
速度更快的工具去进行做
因为整个店铺的服务市场的后台里面的
工具比所有的模拟的工具都要好用
就用这个工具就可以解决
所有裂便铺货搬家的一个问题
那么很多人还会去做财务的统计
那么财务的统计呢
就是用后台服务市场的非鸟订单
这个工具
这个就是财务统计的工具
直通车全部自动的
也有一个15天的免费试用的一个版本
你们可以自己去进行
订购一下
拿自己店铺的账号去订购就行了
选品测品
一键待发呢
就是店铺的服务市场的后台
有一个叫非鸟分销下单
里面有很多剧主产里面没有的产品
1688的产品
很多的供应店都在这个里面
你们可以自己去进行选品测品
自己去进行体验一下就可以了
最后这边的工具
商品管理
包括这下面试用的一些名额
你都可以去找一下我们课程的班主任
或者我们课程的销售
你去要一些免费的积分去经营使用
你跟他说[来源标识已去除]让我来
你免费那边的工具
非鸟商品管理就OK了
这里就是给大家最终去讲一下
课程的一个概述
目的 适用对象
以及最终的一个收获
政客呢
你们可以自己一节一节的往下面去进行看
总之一句话就是站在我的角度呢
我希望你们能把平台的认知
看个两遍 三遍 四遍 五遍
那么付费里面
店铺经营 活动里面
哪里不会
你自己认认的去多看几遍就可以了
因为这个课程我卖的很便宜
几十块钱
不是希望大家支持[来源标识已去除]
而是希望你可以认认真真的学有所获